[Música]
mi vida siempre estuvo vinculada al
éxito vinculada
es distinto que decir ligada vinculada
al éxito porque desde chiquito me
gustaba mucho la competencia sabía que
si juega al fútbol tenía que ganar si
jugaba al voley y tenía que ganar si
jugaba el tenis tenía que ganar ese
primer lugar era casi una obsesión había
que estar metido en el tema ser
vocacional aprender de los errores y
ganar ese primer lugar después empezó mi
vida a cambiar llegué al fútbol
profesional
donde la historia de éxito
en la cabeza hay que ganar
hay que ganar
me fui dando cuenta a través de derrotas
porque si aprendí a ganar en mi vida fue
aprendiendo a perder que el éxito no
tenía nada que ver con un premio no
tenía nada que ver con una medalla no
tenía nada que ver con levantar una copa
fue hasta
los 90 y extendidos
entre al toluca un equipo humilde con
una buena trayectoria con muy buena
presentación con un objetivo muy claro
ganar
ganar que ganar el título ser
protagonistas
ese equipo a través de sus capacidades y
sus voluntades empezó a tener ese éxito
sale campeón
volvemos a las mieles del éxito un año
después volvemos a salir campeones pero
había algo con el éxito había algo con
el premio era efímero
el premio al otro día ya no existía el
otro día había que seguir trabajando
había que seguir emprendiendo había que
seguir evolucionando fue ahí donde un
gran maestro
el profe meza
nos dijo nos dijo a todos los reuniones
dijo la espada el éxito es como una
espada
y todos nos miramos y dijimos
y una espada de doble filo una vez que
se obtiene uno no se puede sentar en
ella esa fue la frase y si la entendimos
fue muy claro fue muy expresivo qué pasa
con el éxito en algún momento creemos
que
y no tenemos ese premio no somos
exitosos hoy creo que el hombre exitoso
la persona exitosa
no es el que más gana no es el que tiene
la mejor casa no es el que tiene el
mejor carro eso puede ser hasta un golpe
de suerte ganando la lotería o con los
jueguitos electrónicos
pero no es ese el hombre de éxito real
es el que se levanta el que se ve el
espejo sonríe el que tiene un sueño el
que tiene la voluntad de seguir
avanzando el que cree que a través de
sus capacidades y sus sueños puede
evolucionar junto a un equipo de trabajo
si ese equipo fue exitoso en algún
momento y si yo conocí el éxito no fue
por mí fue por ese grupo por esa unión
de voluntades por ese trabajo en equipo
por estar anudados
esa es la realidad pero
aunado al éxito uno también conoce la
derrota conoce el fracaso algo que nos
da vergüenza
nos frustra nos da pena nadie quiere
saber nada del fracaso
me gusta leer sé leer
se escribir también escribo y he visto
muchos autores que hablan del fracaso
que hablan del éxito y todos coinciden
en algo
pero lo que me pasó a mí no fue más
particular que esto pero sí descubrí que
el éxito
está vacunado por el fracaso
entre comillas el fracaso es la cuna del
éxito porque es donde uno aprende donde
uno se vuelve voluntarios o donde uno se
golpea donde no quiere golpearse y
aprende a no golpearse de nuevo ese es
el fracaso porque nos da tanta vergüenza
y tanto miedo el fracaso porque le
rehusamos vivimos en un mundo extraño
donde nos
nos hemos convertido en exitistas
somos muy exitista o en la mayoría que
es ser exitista
no están complicadas las respuestas ser
exitista es ser el amigo de el que gana
ser exitista es exigirle alguien que
tiene que ganar
siria el hacer un esfuerzo y hoy las
críticas abundan son gigantescas enormes
hoy cualquiera que pierda en la final
es digno de
crítica de empresaria es un tonto no
sabe hacer las cosas tiene que seguir
preparándose yo lo haría mejor
eso es ser exitista y hoy es preocupante
la situación porque lo vemos y lo
vivimos televisión radio e internet en
el celular somos parte de eso creo que
hay que ser un poquito menos vulnerable
y hacer menos vulnerable a la gente que
es exitosa sin obtener un título sin
obtener un premio el premio termina
siendo una recompensa a un camino a una
voluntad es el compromiso al querer
seguir intentando hay una frase que dice
que como son tus sueños es tu voluntad
como es tu voluntad son tus actos y como
son tus actos es tu destino yo creo que
todos nosotros podemos hacer nuestro
camino y hacerlo de la mejor manera y
sentirnos exitosos sin ser el número uno
esas comparaciones que se hacen y
profesora usted tiene que ser como
mario tenés que ser como a nosotros como
eso es cruel
es de mal gusto es perverso es perverso
y no podemos ser perverso creo que
estamos en una sociedad donde todos
podemos aportar algo y recién la
expresión fue muy clara todos tenemos
que estar anulados todos tenemos que
estar tratando de tener esa mente
abierta
yo voy a contar una historia
es una historia de éxito
[Música]
2009 un deportista
tiene una lección sobre el final de su
carrera una lección importante termina
en el quirófano
él deseaba que no fuera
los ligamentos cruzados para cualquier
deportista del ligamento cruzado sobre
todo cumpliendo 40 años
es algo trágico es el acabose de la
carrera ahí se termina todo y su sueño
era
retirarse jugando esperar el silbato
final tocar el piso dar las gracias
abrazarse con sus compañeros darle las
gracias a ellos
y después irse con la familia a recordar
otros tiempos a contar anécdotas de esos
20 años vividos
en el quirófano el doctor
él pide que
que no lo estés y en total que le hagan
la perdiz dura
lo bloquean está atento a la cirugía y
rezaba sin creer pero rezaba
y decía que no se ha cruzado que no se
ha cruzado que no se ha cruzado y el
doctor el cirujano le dice no fue el
cruzado
y enseguida el chico se quiso levantar
para ver la magnitud de la lesión
un mundo hormigón y lo pasaron a otra
dimensión ya en la sala de recuperación
el doctor de
de la institución los dos cirujanos que
habían participado se juntan con él le
dan la mala noticia se había roto él
todo el aparato extensor de la pierna
una lesión que no tenía precedentes en
este tipo de deportes
y qué bueno la vuelta iba a ser
sin duda algo muy complejo muy
complicado o imposible
ante la magnitud de los hechos se
consultan a otros doctores 5 en total
fue de un lado a otro acompañado del
doctor y los cinco le dijeron
exactamente lo mismo
ya está grande tiene familia porque
hay que volver a jugar 40 años cumplidos
no tiene sentido
mejor salir a caminar con los chicos ir
a la playa
pero él tenía el sueño y quería
cumplirlo
empieza la rehabilitación
dura muy dura donde si mucha gente al
principio estaba al lado de muchos
desalentando los
qué sentido tenía esforzarse un poquito
más en la vida
muchos no le encuentran sentido a muchas
cosas pero él le encontraba algo más que
sentido a lo que hacía
encontraba pasión le encontraba amor
encontraba un porque de hacerlo y ese
era su mundo
el aspecto era bueno venía mejorando de
repente algo sucede
no avanza
vamos a buscarlo en especialista dijo él
fueron a buscar a un especialista con el
doctor llegaron a otro país lo revisa el
especialista hay que hacer una limpieza
trataremos de entrenar con una
artroscopia vemos si se puede hacer una
limpieza y avanzamos
termina la cirugía él despierta llega el
doctor
y otra vez vuelve a verse los 39 puntos
39 grapas puestas ahí otra operación a
cielo abierto y le explica qué fue lo
que pasó
la rodilla estaba atorada en adherencias
pegada a las adherencias al fémur
los vastos internos externo y el recto
el recto de la pierna
ya no funcionaban estaban cristalizados
entonces tuvo que hacerse top las tías
tuvo que hacer injertos cadavéricos tuvo
que hacer tuvo que hacer tuvo que hacer
por este doctor le dijo conozco su
postura es obstinado tiene un sueño
trate de cumplirlo yo creo que usted
puede
una lucecita en ese camino
empieza una rehabilitación diferente
distinta muy tediosa muy
dura
de mucho sacrificio pero encontró en ese
mucho sacrificio era lo que él quería no
había algo sacrificio era una elección
de vida se despertaba a seis de la
mañana iba a la alberca a las nueve iba
a la institución donde estaba se
preparaba todo el material hacía todo el
trabajo de fortalecimiento frecuencia
terapia de ahí salía a otra ciudad
cercana y se iba a ser terapia se iba a
ser movilidad se iba a ser acupuntura se
iba a ser absolutamente todo lo que
podía la verdad
el chico comía poco adelgazo mucho
y se encontró con una noticia nueva
terminaba su contrato en el 2010 casi un
año de la primer lesión
la institución toma la determinación de
dejarlo ir porque era alguien que no
servía funcionalmente
creo que fue frustrante
te llena o se llena el mundo de soledad
de incertidumbre de duda se acabó ya no
tengo la posibilidad de volver dijo
se me acabó la historia
pero no así
prefirió no rendirse dijo en algún
momento voy a tener la posibilidad de
siguió la rehabilitación siguió la
terapia muy muy apuntalado por su
familia por sus amigos y profesionales
que creían en que él podía pese a que le
decían basta
tiene sentido 41 ya vamos a cumplir 41
vamos a tomar unas chelitas salimos con
la chica estaba soltero este señor
con hijos con hijos
y vivimos la vida no necesitas trabajar
no necesitas hacerlo por
pasa el tiempo
casi
22 veces 20 meses y un amigo del que
había jugado que ahora era director
técnico en una categoría inferior le
habla
dice me enteré que estás dispuesto a sí
pero ahí entró la duda el temor el miedo
hacía casi dos años que no hacía nada a
nivel competitivo a nivel profesional
se atreve llega empieza la primera
pretemporada
dura difícil pero con un entusiasmo en
un amor con una pasión con algo que no
se puede explicar que no es tangible que
no es dos más dos
4 no lo es
juega
su primer torneo juega su segundo torneo
antes de jugar el primer torneo se
acerca un periodista y le pregunta
cuál era la necesidad porque volviste a
jugar
y él le dijo por amor a el fútbol
[Música]
termina ese año para el fantástico tal
vez el mejor de su carrera
sin nada absolutamente nada
nada
estuvo muy cerca el equipo de acceder a
una semifinal y poder pasar una final
pero no hubo trofeos no hubo medallas
no hubo recompensas
pero sí hubo un pesar el piso dar las
gracias abrazarse con sus compañeros
y salir a disfrutar con su familia
sé que algunos de sant que es mi
historia
y por qué
[Aplausos]
la quise contar en tercera persona
porque no me gusta hablar de mí no me
gusta que tengan lástima
porque no la tengo por mí nunca he
sentido de lástima de lo que me ha
pasado en mi vida sea malo muy malo o
peor que eso y porque ya no soy ese he
aprendido muchas cosas
mejorado sin lugar a dudas pero esa es
mi mayor y mejor historia de éxito
[Aplausos]
ya estoy como un hito perdón un hito
la tragedia de la vida no es no alcanzar
las metas la verdadera tragedia de la
vida es no tener metas que alcanzar
es una realidad es algo leído pero es
algo que incorporo mucho a mi vida
tolucos jóvenes no tan jóvenes si
quieren ser exitosos
persigan sus sueños
si quieren ser exitosos apliquen toda su
voluntad todos sus sueños sean
auténticos sean ustedes mismos nos
quieran imitar absolutamente a nadie
desplacen desplacen el temor a fracasar
dejen de lado la vergüenza del fracaso
dejando lo mejor de cada uno de nosotros
seguramente el destino los encontrarán
triunfantes uno no
[Aplausos]